Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
and ahhh,
I'm just checking in on you.
How are you?
Um,
it's Thursday,
November 15th and old freckles is off the road.
Hey,
he's dropping pounds right in,
left because he's not up there eating from a chef phase.
Belly.
He's lows.
His freckles.
Sorry.
Um,
I'm excited to be home with my wife and kid.
And speaking of which I last week,
last Monday.
Can you guys remember back to November 12th?
Remember that Trump was still president?
He's still president anyways.
Uh,
was I gonna say,
um,
I,
I read a question,
best friend's wife from a lady and felt that neo needed to chime in.
So what did I do?
I got in touch with my wife's people to try and see if I could poke her on the
podcast and she was nice enough to take time out of her busy,
beautiful schedule as being the greatest mother ever.
Um,
welcome back to the program.
Thank you Nia hill.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me.
Oh well what was it like to work with Tom Cruise?
Oh my God,
he is so amazing.
He is just so generous and do his own sponsor,
did his own stuff.
So he really,
the bangs you in that scene,
right?
Oh my God.
It was great.
He didn't let us do it.
No,
no.
He'd stand in me commitment.
He stared me in the eyes the entire time.
I was like,
wow.
Really?
It's like we're in a real relationship.
I'm telling you right now,
after you got to be Invisalign to be fixed,
that snaggle tooth,
I just felt like it all just went to another level.
His commitment to the craft.
Yeah.
Excuse me ma'am.
We're trying to do a podcast over here.
I got the little one out here too.
When she has her favorites
show on the one created by Harlan Williams.
I can't say the name of it or she's going to freak out cause she's kind of
looking at like why is there no sound?
Okay.
What is,
it's almost the 2020 is not the 1920s there.
Once you have some old lady playing the piano when the corner.
Um,
all right,
Neil.
I know you have a lot of stuff to do.
Yes.
We're going to do a little Bang Bang here.
Going right into it.
All right,
great.
All right.
Best friend's wife from a
wait.
Best friend's wife.
All right.
Hello Billy Baldwin.
Ah,
Yay.
Like it.
Yeah,
but I went in that I like that.
I win.
Yeah.
That's not a bald and I,
when do I?
I don't think so.
All right.
Recently I must say,
hey honey,
speaking to the Mikey rather than chime in.
All right.
Yes.
Oh,
you're talking about,
yeah.
That's not going to be me.
All right.
Uh,
recently I've been posting pictures and videos on my Instagram that are not
slutty.dot dot.
Not slutty,
but I wouldn't show my parents either.
Ah,
ha.
Period.
Now wait,
now where would,
where would you call if you had to rate that as a movie?
Where is she?
What do you mean?
Like some movie PG,
PG 13 are,
it's not NC 17,
but it's not painful if she's showing nip and booty.
So then you would say PG,
PG 13 now summaries,
right.
[inaudible]
um,
I am 26 years old.
Prime of your life.
Yup.
And I've been feeling very confident about myself.
Wow.
By [inaudible] bay.
Vida.
Show it off girl.
I'm going to bring that back.
Lapper do pardon me guys.
Don't dance anymore.
Bring webpack burlesque.
The old stripper song.
Yeah.
Dita von Teese does it not in the club.
What do you mean in the club?
The in Duck Club da na [inaudible] in duck club.
Now that was never our,
are you going down?
Um,
and I've been feeling very confident about myself and my body.
I'm single with no boyfriend or even dating.
[inaudible]
anyways,
my friend,
sorry,
since I was 16 has told me that his wife has been uncomfortable with us talking
because she seen my pictures.
So they'd been friends since camp.
So what happens at Camp?
Nia stays at camp.
That's right.
She,
she's told him,
uh,
she feels insecure and sees my pictures even before he does.
Uh,
he is the following here.
Yes.
She's watching you.
Private eyes.
Yeah.
He has expressed that.
He may not be my friend anymore because of this.
And this is not the first time I've been blocked by male friends because their
female counterparts,
our social media stalking me and claiming I'm trying to get their men,
first of all,
nobody is stocking you.
You're on social media.
If you are hanging these up in your house and you looked and she was staring
into your window,
no,
but you can let go and just be like really looking through someone's feed and
just be like every time they pose looking and not only looking at the picture of
see who's liking the picture and the tie,
like all that kind of stuff.
All of that is all out in the open.
I know,
but like you can pay like up just a little bit more attention to it than a
normal just scrolling through.
Oh,
like,
like a little kid playing hide and go seek.
The first time they hide,
they lie down on the floor,
face down and recover their eyes.
I'm hiding.
You're not hiding.
You're putting this out for the world to see.
And judge,
I've been told uh,
to maybe tone it to tone down my posts or not,
right.
How I feel because the girls take it personally and take it out on my friends.
Uh,
and these are these my real friends order their girls have legit reasons to be
upset.
Yours truly a huge fan and love to Nia and the baby.
Oh,
um,
well first of all I had to say,
I don't know why you're surprised at this reaction because you're out there
thirst trapping and these girls don't want their men to get caught in your trap.
So even though you may not be trying to get done for the white audience,
what thirst trapping she's out.
Their thirst trapping means like you post photos that are intentionally like
sexy or provocative cause you're trying to get legs.
You're trying to get into this,
that they're not just,
Oh this is just me eating corn flakes with most of my breasts.
No,
I don't think that you're necessarily acting like it's not,
but you know that there's just like certain photos that are going to get like
the IEA reaction as opposed to the like Aye Yai Yai.
It's this,
is there any,
uh,
DT going on here?
Teas,
D,
teas,
Dixie,
you kids here.
Oh,
cause I imitate a vibrator.
I don't know that it's a Dt,
but it's definitely like showing you what you yeah.
What you could be throwing around the bedroom for sure.
So I don't,
I mean it's not surprising that their,
their girlfriends and wives or whatever are going to be like feeling some type
of way if they're liking your pictures.
So,
um,
I don't know.
I don't think that you're doing anything wrong,
but I didn't write this.
I don't think that,
um,
they're necessarily wrong either.
But here's the thing,
I feel like the,
we're going back to one of my earlier,
my earliest appearances on the podcast.
Only thing is she's been friends with this kid since she was 16,
so that's,
they're fine.
But I also noticed in her letter that she said that like all of her male friends
are most of her male friends.
So is this another situation where you've got a girl who's got a lot of male
friends,
nothing wrong,
involved male friends,
and it's,
Oh my God,
they're stalking me on Instagram and Oh my God,
there's such haters and like,
are these men really?
My friends,
it's like,
listen,
you just have to understand like you have to kind of be a grownup about this.
Like it's one thing for you,
like I said,
to post thirst trapping pictures.
All your girlfriends are going to be like,
yes.
Oh my God,
you're giving me life.
You're so hot.
Look at you,
Bam.
All that kind of stuff.
That's what your girlfriends and like your gay friends or for trapping me,
I just told you what it was earlier.
I said,
yeah.
when you're posting a picture that's intentionally provocative or sexy to get
likes,
that's like a thirst trap.
You're not really going to hook up with anybody.
No,
you're just,
you're just posting a sexy photo.
But you see for women,
lady,
uh,
guys are showing thirsty for attention that that's what it is.
Sorry,
sorry,
I'm the White Cup on Sanford and son,
um,
set on and rap.
So I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm just not surprised that they're there.
What should she do?
Did she step away from these people?
I mean step away
from the car with your hands?
No.
Do you have
to understand that if you start to move into this space where you're posting
sexy photos,
your viewership and the way people look at you is going to change.
Huge point.
If you're okay with that,
then keep doing what you're doing.
But if you have a problem with it,
then maybe you want to pull back a little bit.
But yes,
people are gonna look at you some type of way.
Women are going to look at you differently.
Men certainly are going to start to look at you differently.
And certainly what comes with that territory is that women are going to be like,
oh,
I saw you liked her photo when she was like,
you know,
bent over being like,
if I could just meet cute or whatever.
I don't know what,
people will insert a point here.
They're both certainly,
you're not going to insert anything.
That's,
that's what I know.
It's a rough one.
Both men and women equally are going to look at it differently.
Right.
Okay,
so let's not,
let's not turn this into yet another,
that's what I said.
You said women are going to look at you differently.
Men are certainly can.
I'll get you differently.
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
so what does that mean?
Just say what you're saying.
Just don't,
don't,
yeah.
Well,
okay,
me just,
yeah.
I mean I stand by what I said.
You think that,
well,
why can't you say that so we can discuss it?
I've been doing that.
Yeah.
Well,
okay.
If Lolo wasn't here,
I right now I would transcribe what you just said to me.
What's his,
what?
I can't,
there's too many f words in it.
All that was that was like if you put a bunch of f words into a shotgun,
right.
Well,
um,
so women know what other women are doing.
I think you'd have to expect that.
You know,
if these women are already uncomfortable with your presence in their man's life,
if you start,
you know,
posting booty shots and all this other kind of stuff and they see that they're
dudes liking it,
they're going to be like,
she wouldn't say that she was bending over and already have that type of stuff.
She just said,
this is some stuff that,
you know,
it's a little more risque,
but I wouldn't show my parents.
Right,
exactly.
Meaning it's,
yeah,
you know,
your parents making sure your knees get back and I was like a priest.
I think you should post whatever I can in the Catholic church.
If you're feeling good about yourself and about your body,
you should post all the live long day.
Just know that it's not going to be this perfect scenario where you can just
post and no one's going to look at you differently.
I disagree,
fortunately,
unfortunately.
That's just the way that it is.
I disagree with that.
With what?
With that you should go and post all these sexy photos of yourself and put them
on social media.
Women cannot not be doing that.
Why?
Why are you telling women what they should be doing with their body?
Is there it is.
There it is.
[inaudible] is so bright.
Yeah,
and there it is from you to tell it like,
I don't think women should post a like who are you?
You don't get to decide what people do with their bodies.
Please not say that expression.
What you don't get to just you guys all sound like children.
Whatever.
I want to say it in her lap trying to police my words.
You haven't even heard what my point is.
What's your plan?
Okay,
my,
my point is bad.
I don't want to hear it.
Yeah,
you have the way you wish the world was in the way.
It really is.
Okay.
Okay,
so to go out there and and and and do all of that stuff and be all provocative
and get all these people hot and bothered,
there were so many fricking cycles.
That's the same reason why you don't go out there and as a celebrity sit there
and in a tree stump or whatever the hell you call it for,
for a,
for a candidate,
all you're doing is just going out there and getting that lunatic in the white
van with the two seats that wants to make a pipe bomb and stick it in your
mailbox.
You're doing stuff like that.
You're a good looking person.
People are going to know you're good looking like the literally social media's
been around so long that that people aren't even understanding that there's no
perspective on it anymore.
Half of these,
so many of these photos that are on Instagram and all that type of stuff,
those were like the kind of photos that were in the beginning of a magazine at a
truck stop like 20 years ago and these are just regular women up.
But back then,
you didn't know where these women,
where you couldn't find them on the Internet.
There wasn't cvs taken.
Everybody's uh,
uh,
information and you can go on and find everybody's address out there and you're
going to go out there thirst trapping or whatever the hell you're calling it,
showing your goods and you're just,
you're playing a,
uh,
there's not a person in law enforcement that there would not 100% agree with
what I'm saying.
This has nothing to do with a guy telling you to do what you should be doing
with your body.
It has to do with somebody looking out for your own personal safety and that
doing that is no different than these f and morons.
You see out there riding a bicycle in la on busy streets allegedly in this bike
lane that's not even painted and they have their headphones on.
You have,
you have completely no responsibility for your own personal safety.
And then when something happens to you,
this is this 100% looked at that you're a victim,
you are a victim,
but there's nothing looking at like some preventative measures.
Like,
why would you go on the Internet and do that?
Just post a picture yourself smiling.
You're a good looking person and you'll attract the kind of person you want to
meet.
You're going to go out there and show your booty crack and you and you and you,
you your,
your ass cleavage there.
I mean,
what are you,
what do you like you even said that if you're going to start showing that
everybody was going to look at you differently,
certainly guys,
now all they're going to think is rude.
One of the Faq,
right?
That's all they're thinking.
That's the best you're going to get.
That is the best you're going to get with those photos and the worst you're
going to get is an efin stalker.
Right?
Okay,
so that's what I was saying.
I wasn't trying to get in your world.
I wasn't over here.
Manspreading I'm just saying doing that,
it's literally like becoming a comedian,
posting something on the Internet and then you're going to get upset when
someone just tears the hell out of it and says you absolutely stink.
And it's just like,
well,
you know,
you're not a victim here.
You're the guy who posted your,
you're the person who decided to get up on stage and people are gonna judge you.
That's all I'm saying.
And I think that women that do that type of stuff,
I don't think because there's so young,
I don't think they understand the level of f and lunatic that is out there.
I don't even understand it because women get it way worse.
So to go out there and sit there,
I mean that's like when you go to the frigging alligator farm and the dangling
those frigging chickens over the thing and all the crops go in the water,
you're out of your mind.
Uh,
well I understand your points,
but I still think that people should post what they want to post.
It's their last roll.
The dice that you're in the herd of people shown most of their boobs.
I mean,
they're not going to get people.
Yeah,
I do.
Because I don't think that you should be living your life and fear of what could
happen or what might happen because of that was the case.
I wouldn't leave the house.
I'm not talking about going after a dream.
I'm talking about keeping your ass crack in your pants.
Well,
I respectfully disagree.
The thing is the points where we're going to have a problem with so and so gets
to be a certain age.
You don't.
You dare tell her that that's going to be okay.
Listen,
we'll see that about it.
No,
no.
I know it's your daughter now.
It's not okay.
I recognize the hypocrisy in this,
but I would be like,
please don't post that type of stuff on there,
but I also know that I,
at a certain point,
I'm not going to be able to control what she does.
She's not going to be sitting here quiet,
already tapped watching cartoons.
What do you mean to have kept up?
What does that mean?
You know,
beyond a certain point.
I mean,
what,
what?
What age is that?
What are we talking about here?
When she's 80 and she's an adults,
I'm not going to go see isn't
I think of what you thought.
Your,
your 18 hours,
the logos.
You're not an adult,
right?
Oh,
you're not okay with you.
And I get them teenage.
Yeah.
You and I get a divorce and I'm,
I'm with an 18 year old.
What?
She's an adult.
You're going to be like,
she's a shy.
Oh my God,
I would kill you.
I kill myself,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just because I lost,
you know.
Oh God.
Oh,
say that no ball romantic little enough.
Sweet nothings.
I don't even know how to be romantic,
do I not?
It'd be romantic.
Um,
Oh,
you know what romance is?
You're not,
you're like a generous like sweetheart,
but like romantic.
No,
I wouldn't say that your romantic,
but no,
I wouldn't argue with that.
You like romantic things you like,
like music,
like dancing,
like in the middle of the house.
Like you like to do stuff like that.
I want to take you to Frankie valley out here in La.
Marque first.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Is that a,
can I have a Jersey boy
date mistress?
Just mean someone that totally platonic,
just somebody that I bring to all this stuff that I,
I,
oh,
you want to find like a 50 year old white woman to take to stuff like that?
Why?
Why do you got to bring race into it?
Cause I mean deldot see fall valley
heavy.
Come on,
let's be,
are you kidding me?
I maybe my mom will go.
Where'd she go?
I take her.
You would take my mom.
I love you mom.
I'll go in a minute.
You got some probably have a really nice time at y'all.
Just too good to be true.
You don't want to see that too.
And he's in his eighties he's still kills it,
right?
Yeah.
That's the guy from Jersey Boys,
right?
Georgia even though one.
Yeah,
go one.
Never laid a hand on you,
man.
So anyway,
back to the question of a million module where my Nias perspective,
my perspective is not as that you're not doing anything wrong by thirst trapping
on Instagram,
but you should know that that's going to come with a,
a change in how you're perceived.
And yes,
they are.
Here's the thing.
If I had a girlfriend who was hot single and she was feeling really good about
herself and she was posting,
you know,
sexy photos,
I would be one of the first ones being like,
yes bitch,
get it.
Oh my God.
Amazing.
Yeah,
get it.
Get your life.
Just get everything.
What is that that yes girl show you.
But if Billy you doing,
if I saw the bill was lacking all of her photos,
I might be like,
now wait just a minute.
So that's just the reality of it.
All right.
Let's see.
I finally got my abs like I finally,
I didn't have to go on the road for,
you know,
and just ruin everything that I got.
I get my abs back and I start,
I start posting shirtless photos cause I feel good about my body.
Be like,
yes,
yes.
Get it,
get it.
Yeah,
I would,
but yeah,
and what I have a problem with women but women already like
are,
are looking for you and trying to like put it out there.
I've seen it.
I assume we're going to see comments,
ladies.
That's what I see y'all sly remarks.
That's one of the funniest things you've ever said.
Just no,
I'm watching.
I've never had that attention ever.
Uh,
it's been happening.
Perhaps you haven't noticed it,
but it happened.
No,
that doesn't count when you get to where I'm at now.
What do you mean it doesn't count?
It counts when you're nobody.
That means you're good looking up.
All of a sudden you start selling tickets.
Hey Baby.
Yeah,
man.
I just like,
that doesn't mean anything.
Look how good she's been.
You liked me when I was broke.
I did.
I fell in love with you when you were broke.
It was a great time.
You know.
I got you.
I was thirst trapping.
That was going to say something else.
Oh,
navy.
Um,
all right,
well I'll agree to disagree on those photos.
I mean,
I think you know
what people are.
Yeah.
It's just like you were inviting like,
I would love this gotta be something up there.
Somebody in law enforcement and stories and all of that,
that the stuff that these people are,
I like,
people are lunatics now.
Like people will already nuts.
But this like this computer with all of this stuff that you can look at like you
couldn't do,
you know what I mean?
Like down this look back in the day near if you had like a crush it somebody on
work.
I mean you needed your imagination when you went home to conjure up some sort of
fit.
Now you just go to their Instagram page and just sit there like an absolute void
or it's not even considered voyeurism anymore.
Right.
And you just sit there,
it's weird.
The whole thing is weird and you go further down and then their pictures on
enough and then you need video and then the video I got.
Yeah you just some weird thing the way she like cracks and egg when she's just
showing you how to make uh,
uh,
over easy egg or something and you get all of this psycho world and then what
happens?
You get so into that virtual world that if you ever asked her out and she
actually approached you,
you then have a performance,
a prob problem because it's,
it's too intimate.
Cause he used to this stuff,
this thing,
there is a disease and you know,
I I'm,
I'm,
I'm not judging anybody cause I felt the ramifications of it,
you know what I mean?
Trying to lay off the uh,
the,
the bad stuff on there if you know what yeah,
yeah,
I do too.
It's,
yeah,
it's just too easy.
So I'm just saying,
I dunno,
you know,
you don't mean to,
yeah,
I'm liberal and I'm conservative.
I'm conservative when it comes to this.
You are conservative when a car is,
you know,
last call it a bar.
I get a little liberal and that has what do you,
what is time man?
Like what is 2:00 AM do you realize that it's,
it's 12 noon in Japan right now,
man.
Oh Jesus.
Okay.
All right ladies.
[inaudible] eyes adored you.
Hi.
How you doing buddy?
You was so good.
You just chilling out.
Excellent.
You watch him.
Pj Masks.
Pj Masks to PJ masks.
I don't know what you said,
but she said no
masks.
Yeah.
Can you say hi baby?
Maybe?
No.
There's no baby there.
Say Hi baby.
All is my favorite word.
She learned all wait,
Halo.
Hey.
Football.
You say football.
Can you just kiss the microphone?
Can you say football?
Football.
I love that.
It's two separate words.
Can you say hockey for sure?
Can you see hockey?
Yeah.
Kashi.
What else?
What else did you teach?
Their score.
All right.
Let me,
I got to read some advertising.
Oh,
it's the family podcasts.
Good girl.
Feel my arms was something and let me read
some advertisement.
All right.
In other
weeds.
Hold my hand.
All right.
Oh No.
Pop.
Pop,
pop.
Puppy,
dog.
No dogs.
That's right.
You're watching inbox.
Where the hell is it?
All right.
Here we go.
Four reads everybody.
Hey Nini?
Okay,
here we go.
Zero.
All right,
you just do the music bed.
honey.
All right.
For any smokers out there trying to quit or if you know someone who is,
there's a revolutionary way to quit called zero,
zero,
zero.
Whoa,
whoa.
Zeroes.
Quick Kit is a new quilting solution proven to increase your chances of kicking
the habit by up to four times compared to going cold Turkey.
In your own words.
Oh,
sorry.
Capital Letters.
Talk about your experience or experience of someone you know who was trying to
quit smoking.
Oh Man.
I remember there was this guy and he was trying to quit smoking but he couldn't
do it cause it was too hard
and then he died.
Uh,
no he didn't.
He's still lift and he eventually quit and I think he went cold Turkey.
I don't know why these people want me to tell you that.
Anyways.
How many times did you slash day try before you slashed?
They were finally successful.
He tried a lot.
A lot of times.
What method already answered all this.
The zero quit kilt kit not killed.
Um,
it's a three tiered approach that includes prescription medication,
nicotine,
gum and continued support through a mobile app.
Dare I say this is like the blitzkrieg onto n c
Atlanta.
Jesus.
I almost forgot the last way.
How would you do it?
Well,
the English channels there,
there ain't off.
How the hell would you do the rest of it and how are you going to get them on
living?
You don't walk across the water,
Huh?
Bring them hope I didn't get done what he did.
He had a hell of a battle plan.
Your advertisers are gonna Increase.
I think we would've rolled right past it.
He brought it up.
Here's how it works.
Go to quit with zero.com to start your online doctor visit.
After your five minute visit,
a physician will then determine if you're eligible to use the quit kit.
If you're eligible,
like they're going to say no,
the doctor will prescribe.
We don't want money.
We'll prescribe your medication and the quit kit will be shipped directly to
your door.
Why is that so hard to say?
Quick Kit zero zero zero whoa.
Costs less than what the average smoker spends on cigarettes and add less than
other quitting options.
Yeah.
How come?
How expensive our cigarettes now per pack.
Nia.
Oh,
I thought you were one of those bad girls.
Smoke it in the board room
lies,
uh,
go to quit with Zen.
Quit was zero.com/bar and for a limited time,
my listeners can get their first month of quit kit to stop smoking for just $37.
That's quit with zero.com/sorry B.
You are ours.
All in capital letters.
One more time.
Hey,
quit with
xero.com/indo Chino
talk.
Need to talk about how every man looks better in,
feels more confident when he puts on his suit.
Could you do that for me?
Every man looks better and it feels more confident when they put on a suit.
What does it do to you when you see me in a suit?
When you see Mike pasty body March,
uh,
no.
You look great in a suit.
You know,
I liked the whole habit dash.
Yeah,
I liked that whole look.
I like,
does it increase bottom?
I like a three piece suit.
I like a nice tie.
Good shoes,
nice socks,
good trousers.
Does that,
uh,
is that increased my chances later on of getting some sort of physical contact
with you?
Consensual?
Of course.
Yes.
Consensual.
I know it's in the old days,
I could just tie you down with my neck ties.
That would have been fine,
but that was considered working it out amongst yourselves.
Oh my God.
They're like in Japan or something where,
all right.
Um,
yeah,
definitely like it when you wear a suit,
visit a stylist.
What if I wore one in the bedroom tonight?
Just showed up.
That's weird though,
because that's not,
I would like that if I just showed up in a suit.
Yeah.
Really?
And you were like the businessman.
Oh boy.
And then they gave you the business.
Okay.
This bit,
this man giving me the business.
All right.
Looks like somebody's gonna be doing some business with Indochino.
Alright.
Uh,
visit a stylist at our showroom and have them take your measurements personally
or measure at home,
uh,
yourself and shop online@indochino.com choose your fabric inside and out.
Honey.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices,
relaxed while your suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a
couple of weeks.
Really folded up like a frigging pocket square.
Just watch as the compliments rolled in.
Oh my God.
Look at your package.
November is November is black Friday.
See Nia,
you guys get more than one month.
Wow.
You get a month in a day.
You get up.
Even our kid knows that was messed up.
Hey,
you get a month in a day
in leap year,
that's 30 days.
That's an official month.
There's the first,
you get all 28 days of February and then that day after Thanksgiving when,
uh Oh my God,
are you still on this rope?
People arrested for Ammo from all races,
trample each other and in a department store,
no gay that I swear to God,
that black Friday,
that should be on the discovery channel.
It's like they should do be doing it.
You know when the Serengeti,
when the water starts drying up and all of a sudden you know you're a zebra and
you've taken a drink next to an alligator and there's a line on the other side
of you.
It's like those mob movies when they try to have a truce and then somebody you
know every wall,
like somebody screws it up.
I'm sorry,
that was the professional I should have said.
Let's go.
All right.
November is black Friday season
meeting 2018 is lowest prices up to 70% off everything.
The theme is all about stepping out from backstage,
making an entrance,
take center stage,
your big moment,
grand finale,
etc.
This week my listeners can,
can avail,
can avail of black Friday pricing by using code [inaudible] at checkout cal
capitals.
That's 70% off the regular price for a made to measure suit plus shipping is
free.
indochino.com plus Promo code up to 70% off.
Incredible deal for a made to measure suit.
Once you go custom,
you don't go back.
Hey Nia,
can you read this thing about a hair plugs?
I gotta go
blow my nose here.
Which one hymns wasn't us.
It was him as in police,
trash me in my hairline.
The whole
hymns,
66% of men lose their hair by age 35 right?
Or if you are a certain red headed comedian a little bit before then is when you
start to notice
thing
is when you start to notice hair loss.
It's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair you have that are replaced.
The hair you've lost.
I asked you,
why do guys turn the weird solutions or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science for hims.com a one stop shop,
a one stop shop for hair loss.
Skincare,
sexual wellness for men.
Thanks to science.
Has your hair falls out.
Doesn't mean you know what doesn't work.
Thanks to science.
Well,
I mean don't they kind of go hand in hand?
Thanks to science.
Baldness can be optional actually.
That's,
yeah,
that's definitely not true.
Hems connects you with the real dog or you been with gimme that good Lord.
That's definitely not true.
That's right.
You came up in the Michael Jordan era.
Didn't you when people weren't even bald,
they just shaved their head because they wanted to be like Mike.
All right,
what the hell am I?
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to for him is [inaudible] dot com and a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and can prescribe you products are shipped directly to your
dealer.
Uh,
my listeners get a free free,
you get a truck?
No.
So get a trial of month of hymns for just $5 today.
It's not free.
I was anticipating my listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 right now
while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or pharmacy,
go to [inaudible] dot com blog,
football,
football.
She just picked up the mic and just,
I love it.
Football in it all year in national honey,
go to four
hymns.com/burr that,
no,
I can't let you have it.
That's f o r a h I m s.com/bar for him,
his.com/burr.
All right.
Lastly,
but not leastly.
stamps.com football,
hockey,
football.
I stopped talking to you.
Yeah,
shake.
Go Pat.
Yay.
That's right.
Can you say Tom Aid?
He's the goat.
He's the best stamps.com.
Can you say Brad?
Marsha,
there you go.
Can you say Julian Edelman?
Can you say
Zidane Know Ciara?
John Michel Basquiat.
Oh,
stop trying to be all artsy over you.
Say Josephine Baker.
Can you say Lawrence Welk?
Beyonce
stamps.com stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your own convenience.
24 seven print posted.
You can leave it.
And I thought that was cute.
Uh,
print postage.
Now I got to Bosnia.
You gotta plug the mic back here.
Oh,
Jesus.
This is what happens when you don't have a producer.
Can she plug it in?
Yes.
Got It.
I got stamps.com never closes Nia,
much like your legs back in the 90s.
Oh,
I was in high school in the ninth.
Well,
no.
Yes.
And College.
So.
Okay,
great.
Posted for any letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any male class right from your computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which can give you time to grow your business.
This is stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the U s service right
to your fingertips.
Tips,
buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
Hey,
take it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of male,
uh,
based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter [inaudible]
[inaudible].
All right.
And that will be the podcast,
the Thursday afternoon
football,
hockey,
Tom Brady.
Can you say bye?
Say Bye Dada.
Okay.
Give me a hug.
Oh,
that's right.
all right.
I'll see you buddy.
Thank you.
Thank you for picking up that guy.
Very helpful.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
I can't say what I usually say.
Oh,
I did say a lot of things,
didn't I?
Um,
yeah.
And have a great weekend.
You sees,
enjoyed him music.
And then we'll come another half hour bonus.
Uh,
what is it from
no,
the half hour from the Thursday show,
uh,
earlier this year.
Oh,
throw that.
Throw back Thursday though.
Bed throwback Thursday.
Throwback Thursday.
There you go.
All right.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
the ex girlfriend's sister,
I.
Hey Billy Birkenstocks.
Uh,
I'm 26,
um,
and still in love with my high school sweetheart.
We've been on and off again for 10 years and I've gone through a lot to say the
least.
Jesus Christ.
Yes.
I just got back from a two week vacation with her where everything was perfect
and we had the time of our lives.
This is the woman I want to start a family with.
And it became more and more apparent on this trip.
Congratulations.
What could go wrong?
Um,
here's the thing.
I slept with her sister on a drunk and blacked out night three years ago while
me and her,
we're not together and we're on bad terms.
Oh boy.
Who bully.
My heart was broken and I had a lot of resentment.
I was 23 drunk week.
Shut the fuck up dude.
You had a dick.
You fucking jerked off to where while you were dating her other sits that get
the fuck outta here.
Don't fucking come at me.
Got a dick too.
All right.
Don't fuck.
And our youngest sister came on to me.
Oh my God,
you victim.
Things were different then and I was a mess.
Listen,
I'm not saying you weren't fucking heartbroken.
You,
uh,
you,
you are fucking psych the next day.
There you go.
You know what?
You just got to check off a whole family.
Well,
you got to love to do is bang them mother.
Um,
that's gotta be called something like the Grand Slam.
You know,
like when tiger woods won four in a row and they was saying he won the grand
that you won,
you won all four majors would be if you bang the mother,
it all the daughters,
that would be the Grand Slam.
Uh,
the amount of guys left or right now,
why the women have pissed?
Uh,
well a year or so later,
me and my high school sweetie started talking again and started to become close
leading up to where it is now.
I had an unbelievable guilt for what I did with their sister.
The closer me and this girl got years later,
it is the only thing that I haven't been honest with her about and I had to tell
her,
you fucking idiot.
No you didn't.
You should have talked to your sister.
And just,
there's been like,
look,
what are we going to do here?
You know,
he's,
is it,
how does it make things better that you told her
that's such as [inaudible] and then like for the rest of their fucking lives,
that's going to be a problem between the two of them.
Ah,
Jesus,
you shouldn't have said Shit and just waited until 20 years later when the
sister,
you know,
who never got married,
gets fucking hammered.
And the guy,
yeah,
well I fuck jasmine 25 years ago.
And at that point,
you know,
what are you going to do?
He'd be like,
yeah,
it was,
dude,
it was in the fucking two thousands.
What do you want from me?
Um,
anyways,
egos a well,
a year or so later,
I mean,
in the high school,
Sweetie started talking again,
blah,
blah.
I had an unbelievable guilt.
MMM.
So I had to test.
So the last night of our vacation,
oh my God,
we were laying in bed and I told her everything.
Okay.
I took a slap.
She was crying for hours and it was as ugly as you can imagine.
Well,
you know what,
Dude,
I commend you.
You got it off you fucking chest.
He goes,
I feel terrible.
And I'm torn on if it was the right decision to tell her,
my friends are giving me mixed answers.
And I would like an outside perspective from someone who I respect greatly.
Uh,
Jesus cry.
I appreciate the respect me.
Um,
I don't know.
Do you know if it was really bugging you and you felt like you had to tell a
good good.
You told her,
you know,
now you don't have to worry about that fucking thing coming out of nowhere.
He goes,
it is still fresh and everything is confusing on what is next.
We love each other very much,
but obviously I fucked up big time.
Do you think this relationship stands a chance?
I really hope it does,
but I'm worried I ruined it.
She seems to be getting through it better than I thought after her first
reaction,
she told me she loves me,
but I really hurt her and she needs some space because when,
um,
she needs some space.
I hope you don't have a brother
because when I'm with her,
okay,
she told me she loves me,
but I really hurt her and she needs some space because when I'm with her,
she can't be mad at me.
I'm not a scumbag and this is completely out of character for me to do.
I just made a terrible mistake.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
I will say the fact that you actually feel this level of guilt,
um,
uh,
you're a better man than me cause I wouldn't have said Shit.
I just would've just been like,
well,
I hope this doesn't fucking come out someday.
Well,
we're having pumpkin pie over thanksgiving.
Uh,
and I bet there's a lot of people out there that live with that secret.
My thing is not only the cowardly self preservation that I would try to have,
I would also,
I'm also thinking like
this is,
I would have handled that situation.
I either wouldn't have said shit or I would just break up with her and just walk
away from it because I,
I wouldn't say a by the way,
I banged your sister and then for the rest of their life they have to fucking
deal with that.
Um,
yeah.
When I'm the piece of shit that did it.
But I have to commend you that you actually felt that level of guilt and said
something,
uh,
because I,
I don't know.
So it sounds to me that you're going to get past it.
So the good thing
is that now you don't have to worry about that fucking grand piano fog crashing
down on your fucking life someday.
So that's the upside.
MMM.
Maybe there's an upside that you told her where she'll have faith in you that
like,
wow,
this guy actually feels guilt about stuff like that so I can trust him.
We were broken up while it happened.
Um,
you know,
let me see if I can get Nia in here for this one.
Hang on a second.
All right.
The magic of the pause button again.
The lovely Nia is here.
Hi.
Hey,
how you doing?
All right.
Ex-Girlfriend's sister.
Oh,
Jeesh yeah.
All right.
Really quickly,
this guy.
All right,
I'll give you the abridged version.
I've been on and off again for 10 years.
Just got back from a two week vacation with her.
Everything was perfect.
We had the time of our lives.
This is the woman I want to start a family with.
A,
here's the thing.
I slept with this sister and a drunk and blacked out at night three years ago
while we met.
Uh,
while we,
me and her were not together and we're on bad terms.
My heart was broken.
I had a lot of resentment.
I was 23 drunk week and her youngest sister came on to me.
Oh No.
I'll tell you.
That's a rough one.
It's a real rough.
Yeah.
You like,
oh,
you make some self the victim.
Yeah.
She came on to me.
Okay.
I said earlier,
I said,
dude,
I have a dick too.
Don't fucking lie to me.
Exactly.
I stop it.
I said,
you rubbed one out to her before you fucking,
yes.
The seeds have been planted for a while that you've been wanting to fuck the
sister.
Don't try to act like,
oh,
I was so heartbroken.
You and the sister are both dirty.
Okay,
so here's the deal.
He goes,
he felt terrible the last night of the vacation.
He couldn't deal with the guilt.
So he told her,
oh my God.
He goes,
I tell Egos.
I took a slap.
She was crying for hours and it was ugly,
as you can imagine.
Yeah,
I'm all right.
She told me she loves me,
but I really hurt her.
And she needs some space because when I'm with with her,
she can't be mad at me.
I'm not a scumbag and this is completely out of character for me to do.
I just made a terrible mistake.
So he's basically saying,
do you think the relationship stands a chance?
I really hope it does,
but I'm worried I ruined it.
She seems to be getting through it better than I thought after our first
reaction.
What do you think?
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's not gonna happen.
You fucked her to the stair.
It's over.
That's it.
Thanks.
So yeah,
because I mean maybe,
maybe there are some people who are more emotionally evolved than I am,
but I couldn't get that.
Like that's her sister.
Like her is not going anywhere and like how's it going to be at like
Thanksgiving and Christmas and like all that kind of stuff.
Like you're just going to avoid each other or just kind of like,
it's weird.
I mean maybe the three of them can have a threesome
sound.
What I was thinking,
you can't,
you can't have a threesome with your sister.
That's disgusting.
That's gross.
I would never want to see.
Just
know each other on these bombs.
Yeah.
Talking to each other.
Hey,
I remember we went to the waterpark.
Oh No,
stop.
Three of them sit down and both this guy and the sister or so repentant and so
whatever.
But like you,
you'd never be able to trust them.
You'd never be like,
Oh yeah,
can you guys run out and like,
you know,
get some extra sugar and more groceries.
Try not to
[inaudible].
Exactly.
So,
and that's the thing.
She might be okay with him now,
but in the end she's going to choose her sister like that no matter how her
sister betrayed her.
That's the sister.
So you are disposable.
You're just like the dude that's her family.
So if you think that you really have to like hands on to her and the sister and
the sister will probably get past it,
but like a long,
long ways from now.
And it'll probably always still be there.
But because their family family betrays each other all the time,
you know,
here's the thing.
I think what she did was worse than what he did.
The sister.
Oh definitely.
If we're going to like put them on.
Who was the worst person that situation?
The sister 100
here's what I learned.
You never do that if you're with a woman.
Okay,
okay.
You guys break up and blah blah blah.
If her sister comes on to you like
you are effectively ending that relationship forever.
Yeah.
And what do you think he told her?
Her and the relations.
You think he should have told her?
The thing about it is,
is that he told her because he felt guilty.
So it was to unburden his own conscious because it wasn't real because there's
nothing in telling her that would make her feel better and oh my God,
thank you so much for being honest with me.
That's the sister.
So I don't know.
I don't really know how to answer.
Nothing compatible that he had such guilt that he had to tell her.
Not really,
because people are burdened with shield all the time and they like,
oh,
I just had to get it off my chest.
And it's like,
great,
congratulations.
It's off your chest now.
I feel shitty.
So was that really for me or was that for you?
Nia.
Renee hill coming here and bringing the love.
Yeah,
I,
I don't,
I'm not with that whole like,
well at least he was honest with you.
It's like for what?
For me?
No,
that was all for him to I burn.
Ever looked at it that way.
Wow.
Yeah.
Not that I don't think apologies are worthwhile or I don't,
I,
it's not like I don't think that you should apologize for something you did
wrong,
but I just feel like you really need to question.
That's what you were saying.
Yeah.
You really need to question your motivations for confessing something of this
level.
You know what I mean?
It's like what are you really trying to do?
A lot of times people are just trying to unburden themselves.
Well,
that's what I was saying,
that the best thing now is he got it out there so he doesn't have to worry about
that grand piano coming crashing down into his life someday.
I'm the same way.
They haven't like fucking Thanksgiving dinner.
What I want to know is what is going on between the girl and the sister.
Cause obviously that's no sister.
That's no real.
I don't know.
That's what I'm more,
something else.
Why that's fucked up is because now you know that the parents know.
You know,
you think she would have told the parents like mom,
what if they know?
Yeah.
And then they got to be like,
oh my God,
we raised a whore.
And I don't think that she's a hoe.
She's at a hotel.
But you guys still make mistakes,
but it's,
that's really,
yeah,
that's issue.
No,
no,
that's,
that's beyond,
that's a power thing.
Yet it is total power.
It is.
I wonder if this was a younger sister and I wonder like who knows?
But that's what I'm more intrigued about now.
It's like what's going to happen with the sisters?
You know,
that's like,
that's some deep shit right there.
So I don't know.
That's like a power thing on her thing saying like,
you know,
it was much as you're into her,
you still can't fucking resist me.
What is it?
Yeah,
maybe so because who does that?
Who goes after you?
Let us to the female mind.
I can't let you in on that.
That's not a female thing.
That's like a dirty ass Ho bitch.
Nasty.
I
don't know what that's like.
I would never go after,
uh,
relatives like significant other.
So where do you draw the line?
What do you mean coworker?
So you're not
just so that people know because you really have strong opinions on this.
So I want to know.
So family obviously.
Yeah.
Yeah,
my family clearly in a relationship with somebody else and you know,
got all that together.
I want to know,
I want to know where you draw the light coworker.
You've,
okay.
You guys occasionally have lunch together with the sisters,
coworker.
Yeah.
And this is something the guy's got like he does like the Paisley tie with the
suspenders.
You know that there were cameras,
this,
that you guys always go nuts about that no belt.
Yeah.
Well if you have suspenders,
you don't need a belt.
So,
but anyway,
um,
what if he has both suspenders and a belt and then you think like,
I don't know what it is that you're trying to do.
Well maybe how would you have both when that,
when that like get that thing,
that female thing where like you'd feel safe.
Like this guy's really going to have like he's going to have an alarm system and
a gun ear and a sword and where to condoms.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know about that.
Yeah.
No,
I mean if they're not involved,
if they're not like in a real relationship.
Neighbors.
Yeah,
the neighbor.
Would you bang a neighbor when I bang like my sister's neighbor?
No,
not use sisters now,
but we're taking family out of it.
I'm saying where,
where is the line where it's just like,
well,
whatever bitch,
you know,
is it that you guys say you put the hand up,
whatever,
bitch,
what are you talking about?
I'm saying,
cause you saying like that's family.
You can't fucking do that.
I'm just trying to find a comedic angle here.
No,
I see what you mean.
I mean neighbor two streets over.
Your neighbor knew them,
invited you over and you went over there.
You know what?
I have a real life example of guy.
Guy was an architect.
Okay.
All right,
I got it.
I have a real life example of this.
During,
during my prom I went my senior prom.
I love somebody else.
Yup.
Wait a minute.
I want somebody who was just a friend.
Okay.
But my friend has biz Markie.
He was just a Fred.
Um,
but my friend went to the prom with this guy that she had just met and they were
set up by another friend.
He went to a different school.
So they didn't really like know each other,
but that was the day of justification.
They just,
they were set up by friends.
So I'm totally innocent.
So really we really connected during prom and like,
as you know,
that was not what happened.
As you know,
my prom did not end that great.
My parents like came and like took me from this house that I was in because I
was dumb enough weight to tell them the truth.
I called my parents because I was supposed to spend the night at a girlfriend's
house,
but instead we're going to be hanging out at this boy's house.
His older sister was there.
There was a whole bunch of us were hanging out.
I was having such a great time that I call my parents and I said,
hey,
just so you know,
I'm staying here.
My mom completely flipped out and she and my step father came and like extracted
me from the home.
So that's how my prom ended.
Exactly.
So it didn't end on any,
it was a very traumatic,
but right.
Parents ultimately they did the right thing.
Um,
but anyway,
he and me and this guy ended up connecting and we ended up like dating
afterwards,
so you know,
um,
oh that's different.
I thought you were saying like,
you know,
like I,
we went in the bathroom to the front part of the Limo and put the window up in.
No,
no,
no.
But it wasn't her boyfriend.
They had just met.
I think she definitely felt some type of way about it,
you know,
only because he chose you over her.
Exactly.
You guys didn't have any sorta like friendship,
friendship?
No.
She and I were really good friends.
Yeah.
That,
yeah.
No,
no,
that's not good.
Oh,
that's a rough one.
But it wasn't
[inaudible] let him rough one.
And we dated for a while.
We dated up in Seoul,
you know,
like I went to college basically,
and that was,
that was the end of that.
So it wasn't like this long,
the term,
you know,
Torrid affair.
It wasn't like he was my first love or anything.
He was just really cute and a football player and like Bob Marley,
you know?
Hey,
what can I say?
Sorta,
sorta details here.
All right,
well that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
and he came hard this week.
Came hard.
You really fucking just put that guy you just said,
you know what,
then that's it.
It's a fucking rapping.
You know what?
I think you're right.
I can say that.
Yeah.
As I said to him,
like,
thank you.
Yes.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper
and it is the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
November 15th,
2010 and a,
I'm doing this one really,
really,
really fucking late.
Uh,
I had to fly back from Columbus this weekend,
Columbus,
Ohio.
And uh,
before I start the podcast,
I want to thank everyone who came out to my shows.
I had six phenomenal shows out there.
Every damn one of them sold out.
People smiling and waving.
I was shaking hands and kissing babies after shows.
Everything was great.
So I want to thank everyone who came out.
Uh,
seriously,
man,
that was amazing.
The uh,
Sun,
even the Sunday shows sold out.
So,
uh,
yeah,
definitely.
Um,
definitely going to be back,
you know,
cause that's how I do it.
Do you show up to my shows then I come back to your town.
You know the fuck you think I'm doing this shit for free.
Paypal.
Oh,
Lee,
the podcast is free.
Um,
but even that is anything free.
There's a price to pay for everything.
My girl is fucking pissed at me right now because my apartment was so goddamn
quiet until I came home and she was praying to God that I had already done the
podcast and she was asking me,
did you have,
did you already do it?
Did you do it?
And I said,
no,
I have to do the podcast.
And she was just like,
gosh,
it's just so nice and quiet.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to do a more subdued podcasts this week.
I'm just fucking with you.
I live to irritate people.
All right,
so I'm going to be doing it.
All right.
What the fuck am I talking about?
I just got off the plane.
All right.
Back from Columbus.
What the fuck do I want to talk about?
I don't fucking know.
I'm starting to take pictures of people sleeping in airports.
Just some of the fucking faces,
you know?
Yeah.
Especially on the planes when people don't bring those neck braces.
You know those people like they're fucking sue happy people during the day and
at night they fly in planes and they have those little neck braces.
When,
when people don't have those,
just watching people's heads,
Bob and all around,
you know that's a good time to be obese cause he got like that built in neck
brace,
big neck brace of fat.
You know,
you want a pillow.
All you do is just lean your head 45 degrees to the right or the left.
You're all good.
I bet they never have any neck pain,
you know?
But what do they do every fucking week on the biggest loser sitting there,
bitch moaning and complaining.
Oh it's so fucking hard.
Really?
You have a body temperature pillow on all four sides of your neck.
I know it's round.
Okay.
But my world,
you still have sites.
So there you go.
Fatties fat people.
I know.
And I know I tease you a lot because you know what?
I'm sick of you.
Um,
citizens that you know,
there's enough fucking groups out there that I got to watch what I say that I
got to tippy toe around.
Okay?
I'm not tick,
I'm not fucking adding another one.
All right.
I've added up to here with the fucking tippy toe in.
Okay.
Goddamned bastards.
Lay off the fudge.
Um,
I first realized though,
it's out of control.
When I went to fall asleep on the plane and I felt like I was laying on a cloud
and I realized it was part of my neck.
Jesus,
how fucking cranky am I when I get off of Goddamn plane?
Um,
anyways,
I was a good boy out in Columbus as far as [inaudible] goes.
I did not booze as far as eating goes.
I did all right.
You know,
you know,
it's so fucking funny is when you go to the Goddamn Midwest and you try to ask
people,
where can I get something healthy to eat like that?
Like there's no such thing as healthy food in the Midwest.
They don't even fucking understand it.
You know,
all they know how to do is to have some big block headed fucking blonde haired
kid come out of their goddamn wife's fucking Twat.
Right.
They don't even raise them.
They just send them out in a fucking cornfields and just,
just have the kid,
the kid grazes until these fucking 16.
All right.
Then they signed him up for pop Warner fucking football.
They can't even find a helmet to fit his big fucking big 10 goddamn butcher
block of a fucking head.
Right.
And then what happens?
Some piece of shit can't beat him.
So what do they do?
They fucking crack one of the crack back block,
whatever the fuck they take his fucking knees out.
Alright,
his dreams over.
He's not going to block for Jim Plunkett.
It's fucking over.
So then what?
He gets a job at a fucking hotel desk in there.
I come walking in,
you know the fucking Pussy,
California boy now going,
oh,
excuse me,
is there a place to get something healthy?
And these fucking people there,
their eyes cross.
I see this all I say so you know,
I'm really craving a steak desert.
Is there a place to get a steak?
And I don't mean like an Applebees steak,
you know what I mean?
I'm talking cloth Napkins.
I'm talking,
you know,
somebody related to a Rockefeller sitting at the bar sipping on some goddamn old
booze talking to a broad 70 years younger than him.
That's,
that's the kind of fucking place I want to go to.
All right.
That's what I want to go to.
And you know what,
this fucking Goddamn idiots said.
He sends me to some fucking barbecue shack.
I'm walking towards it like,
you know,
I don't have a car.
So I'm walking around the hotel and as I'm walking towards the complex,
he told me to go to one of the first red flags I saw was a neon sign.
All right.
We got any steak eaters out there who listened to this fucking podcast?
Yeah,
Dee Dee like a quality steak.
Do you like going to a quality place?
Exactly.
Now have you ever seen a fucking neon sign?
Neon signage?
There's Peter Luger's have neon signage.
I don't think so.
Huh?
Smith and Willinsky now it's always supposed to look stuffy.
It's supposed to look like this politicians in there doing fucking dirty
backdoor deals for fucking defense contracts.
That's what it's supposed to look like.
All right.
Fucking guys in suits.
That's what it's supposed to look like.
And I come walking into this and uh,
and you know,
I don't have enough time before the show,
so I just say fuck it.
And I go over there,
right.
And I walked into this barbecue joint and if you guys have listened to this
podcast before,
you realize I fucking hate barbecue.
I don't like it.
It doesn't taste good.
I think the sauce is just their way of,
of,
of covering up the fact that you're eating a very poor cut of meat,
you know,
eating the fucking Cartlidge out of a Goddamn oxen or whatever the hell they do.
The pig ears sandwich is it really did you get all the cartilage in there?
You fucking moron.
No wonder you got to slather it with all that smoked Hickory,
whatever,
the fireworks,
it actually isn't.
Then when you cook it with whatever,
with all the barbecue sauce.
So I go in there and you know,
and I'm fucking grumbling like the Goddamn fucking old man I am.
So I open up the menu and I just,
you know,
something just pops out at me.
It's just pulled pork.
They got some uh,
some Broccoli and some beans and I say,
fuck it.
You know,
he's cute girl comes over,
right?
Like the round his tits I've seen in a long time.
It was fucking that perfectly fucking round and they weren't fake.
And I was just kept looking at him going,
how are they so fucking around?
And I was like,
you know what?
She probably has on one of those fucking Hocus pocus bras.
That's what it is.
She's probably got an eight cup,
possibly a B Cup.
And I don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They're padded.
But you know,
still it was fun to look at.
She,
she had one of those bras that I think Doug Henning made and um,
masters of illusion,
Doug Henning,
um,
he's a magician.
Everybody with a big space in between his teeth.
Like that fucking guy used to play for the giants who's now on television,
who had a failed Sitcom and I can never remember his fucking name.
Yeah,
you ever had something like that?
You just can't remember the fucking name.
And the same facial hair is Rosie Greer.
What the fuck is his name?
One of the great defense events of all time broke the sack record.
Remember that when fucking Brett Farve curled up into the fetal position,
because they were friends,
the fuck is his name.
He plays for the goddamn giants.
Ah,
Shit.
The fuck I keep thinking Richard Seymour.
I know that's the guy that patriots shouldn't have traded the fuck is his name
begins with an s.
There's an s in there somewhere.
That guy could fucking,
he could spit a walnut at you between his two front teeth.
That even opened in his goddamn mouth.
Um,
anyway,
so I go in there and I fucking order that shit and I'm just looking at this girl
with their round tits,
right?
And she brings his stuff over and they got this little,
you know,
they got the Kansas City,
which is a sweet,
that's a sweet,
sweet or one.
And then you got Carolina's more vinegar base and then we got,
we got the fucking Mexican one that's going to make your eyes water and you nose
run.
And then they had one other one,
the pussy one.
Right?
So I go with the kids,
a city one,
and I gotta tell you,
it was one of the best fucking meals I've had in a long time.
It was apps.
The pork was absolutely delicious.
I loved it.
The beans were phenomenal.
The Broccoli,
of course,
had been steaming since they opened a,
because nobody in the Midwest eats vegetables.
They're horrible people,
man.
They all got big heads and block Colin's,
you know,
that's why they play that smash mouth football.
They're not going to use a spread off fence.
They're all fucking clogged up.
Ah,
just fucking around people.
I'm just fucking around.
I'm,
I'm going on adrenaline here.
All right.
I'm going on adrenaline.
That's all I got.
That's all I got this week.
So I actually,
I,
that's the one time when I didn't eat well and uh,
we're going to talk about food this week.
I went to fucking Pinette,
Panorama,
fucking Panera bread,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Went in there and I got a breakfast sandwich.
Um,
hi.
Sarah can help you down here,
sir.
Yes.
Thank you sir.
Come down to this registered,
sir.
Thank you,
Hi Sir.
Can I help you sir?
One of those places where it's like,
did somebody drug you?
You know,
did Alec Baldwin of Panera bread come in and scream fuck you at you.
You know the whole Glen Gary,
Glen Ross,
and now you're out here with,
with,
you know,
just trying to be all fucking happy
stepping.
You're not dad happy.
So anyway,
sir,
can I help you?
Sarah,
Sarah can help you down here.
You don't have the next person down here,
sir.
Can you down come down here sir.
So I go down.
There I go.
Let me get a,
let me get a breakfast sandwich.
Okay.
We have our choice between egg and cheese,
egg,
cheese and sausage.
Your egg,
cheese and bacon.
I go,
let me get the egg and cheese.
What kind of bread?
Kind of bread you got?
What'd you get the hickory smoke.
We got the salmon flat.
Fuck it.
Just give me a week.
Okay,
sir.
There's no reason to curse,
right?
So I get the wheat and uh,
they just microwave this shit.
I don't know.
It was one of the most,
uh,
it was almost like a joke sandwich,
like a prop sandwich,
like the kind of thing that would be sitting on a plate in the background and
that old show.
Uh,
what was it?
Peewee's playhouse.
Peewees funhouse
peewees uh,
let's give some kids some acid and invite a pedophile over whatever the fuck his
show was called.
I don't know.
See adrenaline one doesn't always work.
That was a,
that was a shit sandwich and the story was even shittier.
But anyways,
this is the fucking podcast for this week.
I need help from you guys.
All right.
Uh,
I went out and I bought some Ram for my computer.
My whole do it yourself kick.
All right.
I know.
I could've gone down to the apple store and had one of those fucking nerds,
that Goddamn body odor walking around with the nerve.
They have,
you know,
genius written on their shirt,
right?
With their buddy Holly glasses and that type of shit.
And I'm like,
how fucking hard can it be to put ram in a computer?
That sounds pretty intimidating,
doesn't it?
Well,
you know what,
I went on Youtube and evidently it's pretty fucking easy.
Take a goddamn nickel out of your pocket,
right?
You unscrew the fucking battery for some reason you,
you a,
you turn right to loosen it.
You know,
lefty Loosey tighty you after and go right,
pop out the fucking battery and there's like two screws.
You remove a band and then there's two switches and the things pop out like
toast.
You take out the old one,
you put in the higher one,
he slammed that fucker back in.
You used to the reverse process and you're done.
But this is the problem.
You need special screwdrivers.
All right?
You need precision screwdrivers.
And I went down to fucking home depot and they don't have any small enough.
So now that I have is insulted.
All the tech nerds out there,
where the fuck can I get these screwdrivers?
I have a Mac.
Oh,
s x or that 10 I have no idea.
Version 10.5 0.8 I need some precision screwdrivers to unscrew fucking three
four bolts.
You know,
I feel like I'm going to,
I'm going to put a fucking Hammy and my laptop.
It's a joke.
You guys should go on Youtube.
Go on Youtube and check or go on the M podcast cause we'll have this v.com m
podcast.com we'll have that video up there.
Just look up youtube videos,
how to add ram to your Mac.
And this guy will show you how to do the whole fucking thing.
It's a joke.
All right.
This is my new kick.
I'm sick of these fucking guys with their Dickies.
Come walking into my apartment,
charging me all this God damn money and not one of them.
Seems like there are any smarter than I am.
So basically they just have information,
information.
Who are the new number two?
Who is number one?
You are number six.
I am not.
I am a free man.
I'm sorry.
Iron maiden flashback.
Um,
yeah,
I'm sick of these guys coming in here charging me all his fucking money.
I want to learn how to do shit myself.
I'm still trying to get the balls up to replace the trim on my doors.
I've gotten to the point where I've watched enough youtube videos where I
definitely know how to get the shit off.
Like most weekend warriors.
Oh,
I can start the fucking job but bring it on home,
you know it's going to be hilarious and or great for my act is when I actually
tried to do this shit and fail and then I have to call another guy over to
finish it because I wasn't man enough to figure it out myself.
And it'll be emasculating.
But you know what?
I'll learn.
I'll stay.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't have any God damn pride at this point.
I'll,
I'll stand right there and figure out,
look over his shoulder.
I'll be that annoying guy.
Huh?
Are you blue collar guys out there who fix shit?
I did that for a minute.
I used to finish basements.
You know in the fucking worst job you could ever do is you'd go into somebody's
fucking house,
you'd go into finish their basement in the fucking cunt would be sitting down
there in the basement watching you do the entire project.
So anytime you made a bad cut,
anytime you know all,
you know all the bullshit that's behind the walls,
there's a lot of knee and elbow work and they sitting there freaking out.
What does that,
is that,
is that going to be a pro?
Like when you go to put the fucking installation and you know
what?
I can't remember the fucking measurements.
I was,
I was a grunt.
I just handed the dude this shit and I remember that like the,
the fucking installation would go like 80% up the wall and then you just reach
over and break off some more insulation and stuff it in there and the fucking
Goddamn broads would get so pissed.
Well what about that little space in between?
It's not gonna matter.
Why are you here?
Do you think we're going to steal your fucking laundry?
Get outta here.
The fuck out of here.
That was a bit late then.
You know what's funny is you just sit there and,
and the,
the fucking shit that would go on between me and the other person I was
finishing the basement with,
you know,
when we realized the person wasn't leaving do they do,
would just be like,
yeah,
hand me the nail gun and you know you do that shit where,
where like the Douche is behind you,
right?
It's basically he's talking to me,
I can see his face and over his shoulder.
I see the person who owns the fucking house and he turned him,
he'd be like,
hey me that nail gun.
And you know,
his eyes would be wide and his eyebrows would be down,
you know,
that look like,
ah fuck.
Ah,
Shit.
Um,
so anyways,
that's probably what's going to end up happening to me.
So this is the Monday morning podcast.
They subdued version of the Monday morning podcasts for November 15th.
And guess what?
Guess what everybody does?
I stutter through this fucking thing.
It is November 15th and old.
Billy boy here has got 30 days and no Busan,
no boots,
not a drop of fucking booze.
How do you like that for fucking willpower?
It's not that impressive as well.
Fucking means a lot to me.
I was actually on the plane reading,
rolling stone.
M and M is on the cover and he was talking about two and a half years of being
sober.
And I was thinking,
that's pretty fucking amazing considering the most I've been able to go 75 days.
You know,
I,
granted,
I don't feel like I have an addictive personality.
I just don't want to have a huge fat head.
Although I could use the side of my neck for a pillow when I get on the Goddamn
plane.
Um,
so anyways,
this is the podcast for this week.
Last week,
I actually began a new segment here on the podcast a inadvertently.
Um,
when I,
when I brought up that movie over the edge and when those kids right in the
school and they locked the police and the parents and the teachers because they
were having that meeting in the cafeteria,
they lock them in the fucking cafeteria and then they start vandalizing the
school and the cop runs up and he's tugging on the fucking chain link fence or
whatever the fuck they put up and he can't get out.
And this chick,
big chick,
like six foot two comes running by with this giant globe.
She runs by the camera and then comes running back,
looks at the cop and goes,
ate it.
You stink.
And pig.
What are the,
what are the most fucking horrific lines I've ever seen in a fucking movie?
And that ended up inadvertently creating a new segment,
best lines in awful movies.
And uh,
I got one for Ya.
Uh,
it is called shark attack.
I can't tell you what the line is.
You have to watch somebody sent this in.
I should say it's a shark attack.
Three just,
just search.
We're going to have all of these,
all of the ship shit.
Sorry up on.
I'm actually apologizing cause I didn't curse.
Sorry.
I said ship instead of shit.
Um,
we're gonna have all these videos up on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
All right.
But for some reason,
if you want to look it up yourself,
if you're a control freak,
I understand that.
Go ahead.
Make your life harder.
I don't give a fuck.
Go on Youtube and look up shark attack three famous line and I challenge you to
be silenced after you fucking hear what this guy says.
I think I just said what it just,
it's the most,
one of the most fucked up lines I've ever heard in a movie.
And you know that that's the challenge.
Give me a line worse than this fucking line in shark attack.
Three famous line.
And also I was kind of surfing,
I started surfing bad movies cause I,
I got into that part on Youtube and a a definitely must rent a definite rental
for me.
I'm taking a month off here,
coming up around Christmas is a silent night,
deadly night,
part five.
I have to watch that fucking movie.
Um,
there's another great one.
Just just go on Youtube and fucking just look at the movie.
Just look at the trailer for that fucking movie.
You know,
somebody asked me the other days like,
you know,
as an actor,
when you're in a bad movie,
do you think you realize it?
You know,
and I think on a movie like that,
you'd do.
But the scary thing is,
is I think on anything else you don't because you're so at the fucking mercy of
the music,
of the edits and all that type of shit.
You just pray to God.
You got somebody good.
That's what I learned in date night when I delivered eight fucking lines.
Listen to me talking like I'm in an inside the actor's fucking studio.
I had eight lines more than a goddamn extra.
And here I am talking like I'm a fucking professional.
Why do I have the hiccups?
Um,
so anyways,
there you go.
People,
there's 21 minutes where I didn't talk about sports.
All right,
so be prepared to roll your fucking eyes.
let's talk NFL football real quick here.
I went one in three this week,
betting against the spread.
I got my fucking ass handed a fucking ass handed to me.
I knew the second year,
you know,
gamblers out there,
you know like those certain weeks where you just,
you just can't see a winner.
Some weeks you get excited,
you're like,
oh fuck,
this is easy man.
Like that that they'll definitely cover.
They're definitely covered.
Course half of them don't,
but I'm not even talking about whether you win or you lose,
but you have that excitement like,
yeah,
I can fucking see it.
Right.
You know,
you're like Def,
the black dude who's,
who's constantly shaving his head and Predator.
I see you over there in them trees,
right?
You're looking at it like that.
This week I was more like Tom Cruise in top gun.
You know,
when he loses his edge and he's going,
yeah,
Nah,
it's,
it's no good.
It's no good.
You know,
turn the fucking playing around you fucking fag.
What are you doing?
All right.
And he says,
that's no good.
It's not good.
I can't,
I can't see anything that,
that's how I was this week.
I just,
you know,
I looked at the bills and lines that I just didn't like.
It hated that fucking game.
You know,
those two Goddamn Jekyll and Hyde teams,
who the fuck's gonna show up?
You know?
So I stayed away from that one.
I looked at fucking Miami and the Ravens and something was telling me Chad
Pennington,
Chad Pennington,
but I was like against Ray Lewis and fucking Ralph Nader,
whatever the fuck the name of this quarterback is.
If for some reason I can't remember,
Edie Falco,
what the fuck is his name?
Flaco Joe Flacco.
Um,
so I step my gut told me Miami,
but I didn't have the balls.
I didn't have the balls to pull the trigger.
So I said,
fuck that one.
All right,
so I bet Tampa Bay,
because they've been working for me and they covered.
And then I just picked two games where I just couldn't,
I couldn't see a fucking winner.
I bet that,
uh,
the Houston Texans against Jacksonville,
I was getting a point and a half.
I said,
ah,
God damn.
Jekyll and Hyde,
Jacksonville,
who's going to show up?
Texans have been consistent.
Fuck it.
They beat the colts.
I'm going with the Texas.
All right.
Lose that God damn fucking bet on that Hail Mary Pass.
But that happens.
And then I looked at the Arizona Seattle game and I picked Arizona and I said,
no,
wait,
Seattle,
Seattle.
I say,
yeah,
Pete,
Carol's not a fucking NFL coach.
And I picked Arizona as I was saying,
Nah,
not Seattle.
So I fucking lose that one.
And this was the worst one.
Pittsburgh plays my fucking New England patriots and I was so Goddamn fucking
depressed.
After that Brown's laws,
the Steelers are at home and they're only given fucking four and a half.
They got that great defense.
They got Ben Roethlisberger,
Joe fucking cool won two super bowls
that held a lot of water with me.
So I said,
fuck it.
I'm taking the Goddamn Steelers.
I bet against my own fucking team.
And I lost that one.
I was my Sunday night show,
um,
at,
at the funny bone and Columbus and I get off stage and I'm going,
it's gotta be like 17,
three or 17 to nine or something.
Pittsburgh and I get off stage and it's fucking 10 to nothing patriots.
And I was a,
you gotta be shitting me.
Right.
You know that sinking feeling you like,
you gotta be kidding me.
Really,
really.
I lost faith in my own fucking team.
I'm running to be able to enjoy this.
Actually,
I still did enjoy it.
It's kind of a win win for me.
Either the Patriots get their fucking asses kicked,
right?
But it helps my gambling record or they go out and win.
But the thing is is I didn't bet on the patriots,
so I can't brag this week.
I can't even bring up the fact that we fucking on the Pittsburgh Steelers.
We are seven and two against those motherfuckers.
The last nine games,
the six time world champion that the fucking Yankees of the NFL,
the Boston Celtics of the NFL,
the Montreal Canadians,
the ones with the most fucking titles.
We are seven and two.
And I,
for the life of me,
I can't figure out why.
I remember a few,
like a month ago when all the jet fans had their stupid green chest hair
standing at attention and I was saying that Rothenberger hadn't come back yet.
And that's the team that's going to kick the shit out of you or until you beat
that fucking team that,
that's the team that I believed in.
What the fuck happened?
I don't know.
So anyways,
and uh,
being in Columbus actually got to watch the browns and the jets game and I,
you know what?
I don't fucking what the browns like Cleveland fans,
I don't know what the fuck you guys did to the sports gods.
That's another one of those fucking towns.
It's just like they just can't lose a game.
They have to fuck it up.
You know?
By the way,
can I get any credit on this podcast for that stat that I created?
Remember I told you,
I said Mark,
uh,
fucking Sanchez leads the League in drop inner dropped interceptions.
Any fantasy football nerds want to start keeping track of that.
I've never seen anything like it.
It's like he's got a little remote control and the football that when defenders
catch it with both hands,
it's,
I don't know what he does.
Like he's,
he's got like,
he turns it into a knuckle ball,
that fucking piece of shit.
I'm joking.
He's actually a good quarterback.
That fucking guy,
he threw a pick.
He throws a pic.
I could have caught the ball.
It hit this dude in both fucking hands,
but because Sanchez throws it,
the dude just goes wall.
Hey.
He took it like you would think it was a hot potato.
Just sort of throw it past himself and then he's like,
Whoa,
well no,
wait,
I think I want to catch it now.
And at that point the jet Diff,
a wide receiver wisely slapped it to the fucking ground.
You know,
I don't know.
In defense of the jets,
I mean they did miss three field goals,
so they should have won it regulation,
but Jesus Christ,
they opened the fucking door.
That's what scares me about the jets is they fucking lose games and they still,
when they got luck,
be a lady to night.
They got there on their side.
And you know what Chad fans,
cause I know you have no idea what it's like to win a championship.
All right?
That's what you need.
When you start saying shit like that,
that's the kind of shit that should get you excited and scares the shit out of
me because if you motherfuckers are actually going to be a halfway decent team
and the people are going to drop interceptions,
I mean how do you stop them
even when they're trying to lose a fucking game that's still winning games.
But jet fans,
you got to admit how fucking insane is that running back.
I told you that guy who's,
I keep forgetting his name,
the guy with the dodge ram grill on the front of his fucking helmet,
who do fuck was talking about his arms were saying that's why he fumbled the
ball.
Oh that motherfucker,
they will write and feel gold.
Just step out of bounds,
protect the fucking ball,
whatever.
Here's my prediction.
I think Cleveland very quickly is going to get over Lebron leaving and they're
going to become a football town once again.
And,
uh,
I am all for it because I fucking loved the Cleveland browns in the 80s.
I loved those teams.
Brian Sipe,
Bernie Kosar.
Ah,
that fucking orange Hellman used to play in municipal stadium and it was always
like fucking minus 60 degrees,
uh,
those games with a shit,
those games with a fucking shit,
um,
cardiac kids.
Right.
I don't know.
You know what?
I actually get excited when a team that,
that's been bad for a long time,
but I actually used to have a winning tradition.
Like the browns were the shit in the 50s,
right through the 60s.
You know,
that's something I should've looked up.
I should've looked up.
Uh,
how many NFL titles that they,
uh,
that they want isn't that fucked up that they,
they don't count those.
You know what I mean?
Like how the Pittsburgh Steelers are a top the league with a measly six
championships.
It's not a measly,
because they've won it in the last 40 something years,
but like six championships is all it takes for you to get to the top of the
league.
You know,
it's fucking 27 in baseball,
17 in basketball.
I always forget what the Canadians got.
The Canadians got like fucking,
uh,
they got at least 22,
something like that.
Jesus Christ's I'm fucking French.
Do she's going to correct me on that one.
All in capital letters,
um,
squiggly lines over different vowels.
Yeah,
I don't why,
why don't they come?
Anybody know why?
Why don't they count those titles?
You know,
why don't they,
they count like a mean,
would it be nice if eagle fans could actually have like 1960 or the fuck they
had at least some sort of championship banner hanging on top of a,
the fucking a Blimpie subway,
sandwich.com stadium,
whatever.
Wherever the fuck they play.
Why don't they went out?
They count those.
Does anybody know?
Is this even Fuckin remotely interesting?
Let's get to do the obscure sports stat of the week.
Somebody sent this shit in,
you know,
last week I started this topic by saying how the last time sports teams in St
Louis lost the world series last,
the Stanley Cup final lost a Superbowl and an NBA title way back when they had
the Saint Louis Hawks before they moved to Atlanta the last four times they've
lost in the finals.
Last Times they've lost in the finals and all four sports is what I'm trying to
say.
We're all from teams,
all at the hands of teams from Boston.
There's your obscure staff from last week and this is the one from this week.
All right.
This is the most fucked up thing I've seen in awhile.
Evidently back in 1973.
All right.
The glam rock was going on,
right?
Let's give you a little historical perspective.
I think this is right during Watergate.
When did Nixon get bounced out?
Like 74
that's right.
Cause he wanted 72 and then the fallout was in 73 and then he was gone.
What else happened?
And we got out of Vietnam as a year before we got out of Vietnam.
And,
uh,
I know chicks are pretty hot back then.
You know,
that whole Mary Tyler Moore look,
and I was never in the Mary Tyler Moore.
She looked better on that show with that skinny drunk.
He used to fall over the Ottoman.
But Dick Van Dyke,
um,
was the other ones,
the ones that did the guest stars and they had,
they had the fucking mini skirts,
mini skirts,
you know,
barely hanging over those fucking Harry muffs.
Um,
anyways,
there's your historical perspective,
uh,
to Yankee pitchers in 1973 I never heard of this traded their wives and kids,
they just switched off families.
And this is the story.
According to the Daily News,
1973,
um,
Fort Lauderdale,
Florida.
March,
March 5th,
Yankee Pitcher,
they go by their last names here because I guess,
you know,
people knew who the fuck they were.
Kekich K,
e,
k,
I,
C H and Maryland disclosed today that they had exchanged families several months
ago.
Peterson moving in was Susan Keck.
Rich enter two daughters and Keck rich moving in with Maryland Peterson and her
two sons.
The pitchers in separate talks said they decided to reveal the arrangement
because too many people knew about it.
Evidently everybody in baseball,
I mean you can't really keep a story like that quiet I guess all around the
fucking spring training.
Everybody was talking about the shit.
So they finally just went public with it.
So,
um,
they thought it was time to clear the air.
And the 31 year old Peterson confided that they hope that you won't make
anything sorted out of this according to Kekich.
I'm sure I'm saying that wrong.
Unless people know the full details that could turn out to be a nasty type
thing.
Don't say this was wipe swapping wife swapping because it wasn't,
we didn't swap wives.
We swapped lives.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Look at this guy.
Fucking sprinkle in a bunch of sugar over it.
Um,
I guess technically he is right to how fucked up or their children check it.
You know,
your dad just taps out.
Yeah,
I'm Outta here.
I don't want to be with your mom anymore.
And you know,
you know my best buddy,
he was always over here drinking beers.
Yeah,
he's going to be your dad now.
He's going to be banging your mom when you hear that Moan and just,
no,
that's not me doing that work or right kids and uh,
I'm Outta here and uh,
I'm going to go fuck his wife and go raise his children.
Okay.
How does that sit with you?
Jesus Christ.
You want to talk them?
If they had daughters you want to talk about the easiest chicks to lose your
fucking virginity to are there you go right there.
There they are lined them up fellas.
All right.
New Jersey where the forehead resided for four years requires simply that the
parties proved separation for a year in order to file for divorce.
It's a no fault rule,
meaning no grounds are required.
You know,
what's amazing about this fucking story is how like that you could actually keep
something like this quiet for a,
for a couple of months because if you ever tried to do any bullshit like this,
uh,
today,
I mean Jesus Christ,
three different 24 hour sports networks and ESPN alone,
the versus network,
I mean then you get,
TMZ would jump on that would just TMZ late night talk shows.
They got like 58 of them now.
Oh my God,
we'll be over manager.
Ralph Houk said it was a situation that he could live with a,
that it would not rip apart his team and that it still had its best chance of
winning a pennant since 1964.
I always liked Ralph Hulk fucking keep it positive and just for the record,
they went 80 and 80 to two games of under 500 Jesus fucking Christ Jesus Christ.
How the fuck he is the top,
that obscure stat.
Does anybody notice that?
I've been stuttering more and more as this fucking podcast goes along.
The Sun is gradually going down.
I got 36 stutter and fucking minutes in here.
Hang on a second.
I gotta turn the light on so I can read here.
Hold on,
just stay there.
Don't freak out.
I'm not leaving you for somebody else's wife and family.
The street.
How the fuck mean talk.
That was like the fallout of the,
the,
the free love man.
Society's rules man.
What does it mean?
You know what's funny is they,
they really,
um,
I saw a great documentary on,
on hippies is literally called hippies and it was awesome because one of the
former,
a hippy dudes was really honest where he just said he didn't like what was going
on and he rebelled against it,
which I totally fucking related to,
but he talked about living in those communes,
you know,
where they were going to start their own fucking churches and their own
education and everything and everybody shared everything.
And He came to the same conclusion that we all come to is that basically other
people are fucking irritating
and you want to get away from him.
And that's basically what happened at the commune,
at least for this guy.
Like he was hanging out and have a free love.
And all this type of shit.
And after awhile you're just like,
oh my God,
I gotta,
I gotta get,
I gotta get the fuck away from these people,
you know?
So you really gotta hand it to the native Americans how they were able to live
like that and somehow,
uh,
you know why that is of course is because they didn't realize they didn't
understand the concept of having an apartment much less a fucking door.
Um,
all right.
That was pretty ignorant.
That's plow head.
Oh,
by the way,
I've really pissed off a lot of potheads evidently on my podcast.
They think that I,
I am against smoking weed and then I'm trashing that whole fucking lifestyle.
Why don't you guys go take another hit off your fucking blunt and fucking relax.
All right.
Just because I trashed that guy
who was a pot smoker.
I wasn't saying that weed was a bad thing.
All right.
At this point,
with those vaporizers that they have,
it's probably fucking 10 times healthier than sitting around drinking a six
pack.
I don't have a fucking problem.
I wasn't talking about smoking weed.
I was,
I wasn't,
I was making fun of a loser.
I was telling that woman that she was dating a fucking loser.
All right?
As a man,
your job is to go out and fucking provide,
you know,
and when somebody breaks into your house not to shit yourself and to grab the
nearest blunt object and fucking go Braveheart or Ana,
that's what you supposed to do.
You know me,
I would shoot myself,
lock myself in the bathroom and call nine one one of course,
but I can provide God dammit.
That's what I got to fit fucking pit bull for.
Um,
speaking of that,
I watched no country for old men again,
man.
What a fucking awesome movie that is.
That is just absolutely phenomenal fucking movie.
It actually made me sad that we were in final descent.
That's how good that goddamn movie is.
Um,
but anyway,
so I just know that potheads I'm not making fun.
You know,
if I make fun of some guy who's a booze bag,
booze bag,
fucking losers sitting around drinking beer all day on the couch,
that doesn't mean that I don't think that anybody should drink.
All right,
so fucking relax.
Jesus Christ.
I thought you got mellow when you smoke weed.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead.
Hey products.
Can you guys basically just admit that you want weed to be free just so you can
just sit around smoking it and not have to worry about anybody hassle in Ya,
you know,
to use a classic Hippie word,
why can't you just admit that and stopped telling me about,
you know how the fucking declaration of independence was written on hemp and
all,
all these,
you know,
I mean Jesus Christ,
you can make a potted plant out of a 40 in empty 40 ounce.
I'm not going to sit there and act like I don't wish that I want to drink in
public.
Right?
Dude,
my brain shut down seven minutes ago.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about?
I need to start reading again.
Overrated.
Underrated for this week,
everybody.
Um,
all right.
This guy said underrated banana pancake.
Damn.
I made a simple pancake with bananas in it and I had some,
uh,
some great real maple syrup from New Zealand and it was fucking amazing.
I couldn't believe how great it tasted.
I never was a pancake guy.
And when I used to go to,
I was never pancake guy when he used to go to diners back in Jersey.
It was delicious but overrated to banana pancakes.
All right.
I got greedy.
I thought the first one was so good.
I went back and made a second one man,
was I wrong?
I ate it and felt like a gluttonous pig.
I should've known,
but I,
at least for temporarily temporarily forgot.
Happiness comes in spurts and too much of anything can be bad.
I hate to relate life to a couple of pancakes,
but it's true.
I overdid it and ruin the great single pancake experience.
A one and it was great.
I had a second and I felt like shit.
Yeah,
there you go,
dude.
Dude.
Batter.
Pancake batter is a edible cement.
That's what it is.
All right.
I told those stories before for all you struggling comedians out there,
you don't want to blow a bunch of cash on food,
go down to Denny's or an Ihub and about nine 30 in the morning,
get the fucking full stack of pancakes and force.
I didn't even know if they make them anymore with all this talking about
nutrition,
I don't even think back in the day they give you five and you just,
I just like man versus food.
I just shoved that.
She'd be sweating by the time he got to the third one,
all that syrup and all that butter.
And then you'd suck down your water in the,
and I swear to God you weren't hungry again until like 10 o'clock at night.
So you got to skip at least one fucking meal.
You know,
just a tip.
Just a tip for you.
Let's wind this podcast down.
Let's go short and sweet this week shall we,
uh,
youtube videos for this week.
And I'm going to tell you right now,
and I think these are arguably the best fucking youtube videos,
the best cluster of youtube videos that,
um,
that you guys have suggested since I've been doing this topic because you guys
have,
are now actually going outside the realm of youtube in finding some really
obscure shit.
So for all of you,
they're listening at home.
Just go to the MM podcast.com and uh,
we'll have all of these lined up for you to watch.
All right,
here we go.
First a youtube video.
And this one right here is an instant fucking classic.
I absolutely love this guy.
Uh,
this youtube video is called man is tased mocks cops and still gets away.
I want you guys to watch this because not only is it fucking hilarious,
but this guy really shows why it's so important to know what your rights are as
as a citizen.
I'm not saying the cops aren't still gonna kick the shit out of you,
but just to watch this guy,
he's actually stumping the cops on a certain level because they can't answer his
questions.
They got pinned on the ground and they said,
go and sir,
you're underneath the rest.
You're,
do you realize you're aren't ya?
You're aware that you're under arrest.
And he goes,
no.
He goes,
what's the charge?
What is the charge?
And they just kept going,
sir,
are you aware that you're under arrest?
He's like,
I don't speak the language.
I'm not in your king.
I'm not a subject.
Subjective,
your kingdom.
Right.
And for the first minute and 20 seconds,
this guy's fucking hilarious.
Then he gets all religious or oh gee,
she's,
and then it gets thin.
He looks like a freak and then he just starts singing this fucking song and
they're trying to handcuff him and he is doing the most simple fucking move with
his elbow.
Really looked to see it.
The cop keeps going over the risks go under the risk over the wrist,
under the wrist,
and he just keeps moving his fucking elbow.
It's literally a two inch move.
He's moving it up to inches and down to which is in this fucking cop cannot get
the goddamn handcuffs on him.
And the whole time he's doing this,
he's singing this fucking song.
He's like a poet or something like that.
Then they tase him and as they're tasing him,
he's standing up and he's,
he's presenting his case because his wife is filming it.
As he's getting tased,
he's standing up going,
I defending myself.
I am defending myself from this unjust tasing.
And then he runs away
one of the greatest youtube fucking videos ever.
This guy is,
is my fucking hero.
I love him.
All right,
and let's stick with the Arestin this week.
Uh,
another one is a funny arrest and this is black dude getting for drinking and
driving.
And this guy is absolutely fucking hilarious.
He is adamant that he was not.
He goes,
I have been drinking,
but I wasn't driving.
I sat,
I was begging,
I want grabbing,
you got to see this guy.
I'm 70.
Motherfuck,
I'll take no mother fucker tests.
And then they,
and as he was yelling,
the lady would be like,
sir.
And he just go,
Yo,
why am I trying to reenact these?
These are all fucking hilarious and um,
be fair and balanced.
We got a drunk black guy.
Now we got a drunk fucking white dude,
uh,
drunk redneck arrest.
And this guy isn't drunk.
I guess he is drunk,
but he's fucking,
he's one of the angry as he says,
the meanest shit ever.
The cops going to arrest him.
Um,
I'll just give you a little quick little,
uh,
youtube trailers.
They go to arrest the guy and they already got them fucking handcuffs in the
cops.
Go and listen.
Now.
Come on man.
We don't want to have,
we don't want to have to hurt you.
And guys like,
I know.
I don't want to have to hurt you either.
Break your fucking nick.
Oh,
fuck it.
I can't make up funny.
Just go watch him.
Um,
oh.
Silent night.
Deadly night,
part five.
Watch that movie trailer.
Um,
for those who have weak of stomach,
do not watch this reporter Shit herself during interview.
She has on white pants too,
just to warn you.
Um,
and what is the last one?
Oh the last one for all the drummers out there,
I had a bunch of musicians,
uh,
specifically drummers send me all these,
all these emails this week.
I had no idea the amount of musicians and the amount of drummers in particular
who listened to my podcast.
Everybody,
I,
you've got to check out Stewart Copeland,
Danny carry all these fucking people actually read something and rolling stone
about Phil Collins today and uh,
for as much shit music as he made in the 80s,
like that guy's a fucking a fucking beast of a drummer.
Left handed drummer,
still plays those concert toms with the no bottom,
no bottom heads.
This guy,
I'm telling you,
there's not enough.
If anybody's got a great youtube video that just has him just playing,
I don't want to hear him solo in with Chester Thompson who was another great
drama.
I just want to hear him by himself.
That guy is a fucking beast.
And the sad thing is he stepped out behind the kit and it was good in the
beginning and then the end,
it was just,
you can't hurry love since his studio.
Just some of the worst fucking music ever made.
Um,
and they're actually actually checked out rolling stone.
He has this whole article with it.
Either he's talking about how,
you know,
he became the antichrist.
He's actually confused as to why that happened.
So I kind of felt bad for him as an artist,
but it's like,
you know,
look back on that music.
Phil,
do you really think that fucking holds up?
She seemed to have at a vigil boat.
Cha Cha Oh,
oh geesh.
Terrible music.
Um,
anyways,
so checked.
So somebody,
everybody was sending me these videos of drummers tell me all this shit that I
should check out.
And uh,
this was the,
this was the drum video that really stood out for me.
Um,
two things.
One,
this is a video I already knew about.
If you guys are into like drum and bass music,
or if you're drummers out there and you wonder where that fucking music came
from,
this is video that explains,
says a video video,
explains the world's most underrate,
most important six second drum loop.
And it's,
um,
it's basically this,
this song from a sort of obscure,
I guess R and B group called the Winstons and uh,
they had this song called amen brother,
which was actually a B side and it had like this,
uh,
I don't know what it was.
It was like,
I don't know musically how to say it was like a fucking two bar drum break that
these,
uh,
I don't know if people used to rap over it and what they explained the whole
fucking thing and basically how Dj's took that to bar drum brake and isolated
every sound
of,
of the recording,
every like,
I don't know how to musically,
like if you could cut it down to like 32nd notes,
they just isolated everything,
the sound of the ride cymbal,
the sound of the bass drum,
everything in the sign of all of it together and just spliced the whole fucking
thing up and then re edit it in different,
in a different order and then sped the whole fucking thing up.
Created all these new drum beats and cr in sped,
the whole fucking thing up past the point where human beings could actually play
drums at that point.
And,
but what's great about fucking human beings is I like to believe is that we're
better than fucking machines.
So the great dramas of the world's figured out how to fucking play that fast.
That's a whole nother thing.
Guys like Joe,
Joe Mayor actually through fucking does these different techniques to play in
molar method,
push Polen all that.
They figured out how to fucking play at that level.
But this video explains basically how all that drum and bass should kind of came
about.
And a checkout Jojo mayor to another drum video we'll have up on the [inaudible]
podcast.
If you're interested in that shit.
How,
how fucking fast this guy can play and single bass drum players.
I got to show you this fucking video.
This guy can get three and four bass drum hits in a row like row row crop,
like doing like that heel toe shit.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It's unfucking believable how this guy can do that.
Um,
anyways,
I know I'm boring a lot of this,
this is even more fucking obscure than sports.
But anyways,
that all the drum videos you guys sent me,
a lot of them I knew.
And one,
this is the one that I was the least familiar with,
cause I figure everybody knows Danny carry in a tool and all those major bands.
But uh,
there's this band called Russian circles,
which I had never heard of.
Um,
and they have a drummer called Harper Louis and there's a,
there's a youtube video called Russian Russian circles.
Harper Louis,
uh,
live at wicker park fest oh seven.
And it just starts off with,
you know,
eight just this fucking guy.
If I could play drums at this guy's level,
this dude's basically,
you know,
as much as you want to be the guy hitting fucking 8 million drums and smashing a
gong that's on fire,
when it really comes down to what you want to be able to fucking be this God
damn bad ass and still be playing for the song.
It's like,
it's Kinda like that David growth thing.
He's another fake the drum and the David Grohl did on a queens of the stone age.
It's like,
it kind of reminds me of that.
It's like he just,
Ah,
it's fucking unreal.
The whole,
it's all there.
It's all fucking there.
The dynamics,
the building,
the excitement playing,
you know,
not getting in the way of anybody else he's playing with.
He sees the fucking shit.
Um,
and I got to download some of their shit's so if anybody knows what their best
album is,
Russian circles,
please let me know.
And I'm downloading that shit this week cause uh,
I'm fucking the drummer alone.
I got,
I got to listen to more of this stuff.
All right.
I know I'm babbling on here.
I'll,
we'll end with this this week.
All right,
a little bit of advice here.
Listen to this fucking situation.
This guy got himself into,
um,
all right,
bill,
my girlfriend is 10 years older than me.
Oh,
Jesus.
She has two kids.
Oh Jesus.
And has been married and divorced twice.
Dude,
what the fuck?
I'm 26.
Jesus Christ college graduate.
Has any of this made any sense to any of you?
Would anybody else be out there?
26 college fucking graduate,
have a girlfriend 10 years older than you with two kids had been married and
divorced twice.
Good God man.
He goes,
I consider myself somewhat intelligent.
I'm sure you are,
but not in this area.
Um,
by that I mean you should have no problem understanding this email.
Well,
yeah,
I know everybody trashes me.
I know,
I know.
I'm the worst when it comes to reading this shit.
So anyways,
here we go.
He says,
four weeks ago I found text messages to some dude on my girlfriend's phone that
although innocent enough made it clear that whoever she was texting was on more
familiar grounds than just some work colleague or a friend,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
is there going to be a happy ending here?
I confronted her about it and it predictably led to a lot of finger pointing.
We went back and forth and uh,
and uh,
for a few days and aired out our grievances,
but it seemed agreeable.
Now he makes,
I guess point number two,
two oh two more weeks passed by.
And Lo and behold,
I find more text messages from the same fucking guy.
At first I tell myself,
okay,
maybe she can't break things off with this dude so quickly,
Jesus Christ.
Do you know sometimes liberal thought is a,
is a great thing.
Like let's have a fair fucking trial for somebody before we hang them from the
nearest tree.
But then this times it's fucking stupid.
This is just liberal thought to the,
I mean,
how much of a benefit of the doubt can you give somebody,
you know?
So he goes,
so I confront her about it and this leads to another round of finger pointing.
At which point she tells me to pack my shit and leave.
I'll dude,
I'm gonna tell you right now before I read the rest of it.
That's fucking great.
You didn't have to do any dirty work.
You're out.
You fucking out.
So anyways,
he goes,
were separated for a week when she asked me to come back and move in.
Dude,
this chick is a fucking psycho.
Here we go.
We talk about our future together,
how,
sorry she is to have done that to me,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
For Fuck Sakes.
We even talking about getting married when things finally fucking evened out.
I was full of piss and vinegar and felt vindicated,
vindicated that I was the one wronged in the whole situation and that she was
actually making good by taking responsibility for what she had done
through take responsibility would have been fucking [inaudible] to the second
you see those weird texts.
Just get,
I'm telling you right now,
just get out of the relationship.
There is an oh,
sorry.
Sorry about that.
And now that that's it.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
Um,
but whatever,
you're 26,
I guess you still haven't learned.
I was dumb in my twenties.
So here we go.
Let's read the rest of this.
Um,
all was well and good until she didn't come home this Thursday night,
November 11th.
She came in Friday morning with no explanation,
no pology,
no nothing.
She asked me to give her some more time,
but I decided to cut bait and just get the fuck out of this situation.
Hang on a second,
everybody.
Sorry,
I had to give him a little applause break there.
Of course,
now I'm wracked with guilt of leaving the woman I loved and live with for the
past five fucking years.
You've got winter when you were 21 dude,
she was 31 wait,
let's do the math.
She was 31 you were 21 she was already married twice.
All right.
This chick's is psycho and you know what that means?
She's fucking great in bed.
You at 21 she fucking devastated you with fucking her pussy,
right?
Best blow job you ever had is now what happened.
And next thing you know,
you were too fucking
too young and dumb media you fell for.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
He stayed there for five fucking years.
So anyway,
I guess just check,
still calling him telling she still wants to get back together.
I feel like every time I sack up and do what I think is best for me,
she wants me back.
And every time I do what's best for us as a couple,
she uses that as an opportunity to fuck with me all over again.
Yes.
Yes,
you're absolutely right.
Listen to your gut,
this guy,
see,
he knows the fucking answers.
He's,
he's listening to his gut.
Good fucking man.
Um,
is this,
is it just that chicks can't handle a guy that is emotionally invested or do I
just happen to be dealing with one of those sociopath's that doesn't give a fuck
what she does.
So long as it suits her in the moment.
Yes.
There's plenty of fucking good women.
That was not plenty of good ones.
There's good women out there.
All right?
Just like good.
A good man's hard to find this.
Finding a good woman's also difficult.
All right.
But no,
you happen to be dealing with an absolute fucking sociopath.
All right?
She had a fucked up childhood.
Something happened to her.
She got touched.
Her fucking dad took off.
I don't know.
Or She just got the fucking,
she got one of those bad brains,
you know,
I began to tell you guys my theory on that,
the a brain,
the bee brain and the sea brain,
the brain is the genius to be brain is the,
uh,
oh,
he's a good fucking shit.
You know
Fitzy and then the sea brain is your fucking mouth breathing moron.
All right.
And when it comes to being a sociopath,
that's like just a,
that's just like getting an option on the car.
All brains come with that option.
It's all available like satellite radio,
you know,
you get satellite radio and a fucking Bentley.
You can also get it my fucking Prius.
All right,
so did they make any fucking sense?
You've got a sociopath with the fucking,
she could even have the a brain.
That's the sad thing about having a fucked up childhood.
She could actually be a fucking genius,
but she's got the sociopath shit.
So tell her go call fucking doctor Dro.
All right?
And you get the fuck out of the relationship.
So anyways,
he'd say,
I'd imagine you'd agree that I did the right thing.
Uh,
but it always helps to get a little bit of press,
better perspective on it.
Dude,
I totally understand.
You've been in a five year relationship,
you're emotionally invested in this shit.
So you know what the right thing to do is,
but your emotions keep fucking with you.
All right.
So what you got to know is just look,
going through a breakup is painful.
All right?
It's not going to not be painful,
but just because it's painful doesn't mean that it's not the right thing to do.
You are 100 fucking percent doing the right fucking thing.
Your 26 year old years old,
you're in the prime of your fucking life.
All right?
Get out of that situation.
Okay?
She's 10 years older than you.
By the time you're 29,
she's going to be hitting fucking menopause,
all right?
Or something like that.
Whatever.
Sliding into it.
I have no fucking idea what she's going to be doing.
She's going to be wearing those mom jeans at that point if she's not already,
which I don't think she is.
She's probably that fucking,
you know that,
uh,
that anorexic cougar look,
you know where they got a varicose vein in between their fucking,
you can see their breast plate.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
He'll stay on topic.
Yes.
So to just get out of that,
hang out with you fucking fellas.
No,
I ain't call your buddies.
Go out and fucking have some bears.
Join a gym,
get fucking shredded.
Go Out,
start talking shit when you're ready.
But don't go back to that man.
You dodged a fucking bullet.
The fact that you were with her for five years and you didn't knock her up and
you got out of it,
and even after five years,
you're only 26 years old,
you've made the best fucking move.
You're going to make sure,
all right,
and now this is what you need to do.
You've been in a relationship for five years.
You need to be single for at least a fucking year and a half.
And I don't mean just be single and fucking booze.
Figure out what the fuck you looking for.
All right?
And when you meet a girl,
if she doesn't have it,
just walk a banger and leaf.
You know,
there's nothing wrong with having a good fucking time,
but do not get sucked into another fucking relationship because you're going to,
cause you're going to have to go through this shit again.
You know,
we,
you just sit there and you know it's fucking wrong,
but you don't want to go through the fucking pain of it and you keep coming
back.
It's a fucking nightmare.
Good for you,
sir.
I'm fucking proud of you.
You did the right thing.
You sorta fucking wavering cause you go through the motions.
You're only 26.
She got with her when you were 21 is probably your first major fucking breakup.
So it's acceptable that you fucked up and went back that second time,
but do not go back again.
And if any of your fucking friends are listening to this,
don't let him do that shit.
All right.
Time to a fucking barstool and start throwing drinks down his throat.
Ah,
that's it.
That's the Monday morning podcast for this week.
Uh,
anything else?
Where am I going to be this week?
Oh,
this week I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the listener theater in Washington DC.
There's only a,
I believe,
oh,
under a 100 tickets left.
I'm doing a bunch of radio,
so if you want to come out,
please come out.
I'll be hanging out afterwards doing a meet and greet.
I have my brand new DVD,
let it go.
I'll be signing up,
taking pictures and all that type of shit.
Uh,
Saturday night I got two shows at comics at Foxwoods.
Both shows are sold out,
but for those of you who have tickets,
I will be showing up with my DVDs afterwards,
shaking hands,
sign and DVDs,
doing all that bullshit.
And,
uh,
thanks to everybody's been coming up to me after shows,
telling me how much they've a,
that they liked the,
uh,
the podcast and enjoy my latest special really means a lot to me.
And,
uh,
that's it.
You guys all have a great week.
A,
sorry,
the podcast is so late this week and,
uh,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
See?
Yeah.
[inaudible].